[Musik]
calimera meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen die heute zu einer
weiteren episode minecraft mit luca
staffel 2 dahinten schild zum vetter
lachs an der wasseroberfläche
wir haben hier vorne immer noch den
was eigentlich von mir oben
etwas mit wölfen auf jeden fall dass
opel auch in den kommentare geschrieben
dass ich die teilnehmer 100 nennen aber
es sind eigentlich wölfe was man da
hingehen allerdings auch geschrieben
wurde war luca du hast hier fünf knochen
noch in einer kiste das heißt damit
kriegt es eigentlich sie hin die hier
direkt mal so einen hund zu holen
deswegen würde ich sagen wir schleichen
uns herrn es langsam an bei einem hund
und versucht neuen meister
das ging jetzt tatsächlich ziemlich
schnell wir können ein bruder
hatte klappt das immer beim ersten mal
das ist doch nach makrele
kein bock auf dich da hatte ich aber
dreimal gerade richtiges glück die drei
hunde hier können wir jetzt auf jeden
fall mal kurz mitnehmen zu unseren
kisten hier vorne denn ich muss die
ganzen sachen ihr vorne wieder ein paar
lachse ich muss die ganze sache hier
mitnehmen und einpacken ach guck mal das
ist jetzt das wird jetzt stressig für
dich berühmt ja das hätte ich mir auch
vor irgendwie denken können in der
letzten folge habe ich euch in den
kommentaren gefragt ob ich
habe noch ein paar mehr knochen
ihr bleibt erst mal ganz kurz ich aber
jetzt schauen wir mal ob
ich mir sogar noch mehr hundehalter ich
mach dir hier 100
nato schlawiner
ich habe
jetzt einfach vier hunde am start
ja
das war eigentlich gar nicht das ziel
für die heutige episode denn meine
lieben freunde ich habe euch ja in der
letzten folge minecraft mit luca gesagt
dass ihr einfach mal in den kommentaren
schauen könnt nach den kommentaren die
ich selber geschrieben habe und
dementsprechend könnt ihr selbst
entscheiden was sich in der heutigen
episode machen soll und das ging so
aussehen dass er um wieder der schwabe
war
[Musik]
dem wert waren die los die sache ist auf
jeden fall meine lieben freunde dass wir
uns wirklich was ist denn hier von lachs
aufkommen
auflagen ihres seit vier minuten wir
haben uns bisher nur lax haben und
[Musik]
ganz gute tipps ich meine sachen
zusammenpacken
so meine lieben freunde diese ganzen
items hier habe ich mir jetzt mal ein
gesteck dementsprechend habe ich das
alles hier gelassen und das alles also
dinge die ich glaube ich jetzt wirklich
nicht unbedingt brauche den schmelzofen
dass sich auch hier und die werkbank
auch wir wollen jetzt erst mal nur
entdecken und das können uns ganz
schnell neue kräften deswegen jetzt
erstmal alle vier hunden hier wieder die
erlaubnis erteilen das ist mir folgen
dürfen die laufen jetzt hinter mir her
zum mode teleportieren die sicher auch
ich glaube ich hab keinen dahinten
vergessen nie alle vier sind hinter mir
der rabe der dahinten vorhin gechillt
hat den lasse ich einfach hier der wt
mitkommen und die sache jetzt dass wir
jetzt einfach mal weiter laufen wir
laufen hier vorne an dem dorf jetzt mal
vorbei mir wurde auch in die kommentare
geschrieben luca baumann das lesepult ab
und wieder hin dann kannst du diesmal
direkt eintauschen jetzt sind alle froh
dass du dich vermisst
ich sagte ja gar nichts mehr zu wir
wurden einige tipps und in die
kommentare geschrieben allerdings dass
ich dieses dorf jetzt erstmal hinter mir
vielleicht finden wir ja noch ein
weiteres ein weiteres dorf die beiden
ihr keine ahnung was da abgeht wir
bewegen uns einfach mal in diesem wald
hier vorne da rein ich bin nämlich
eigentlich
ist es ein bisschen doof dass ich jetzt
schon muss lauf oder wenn die sonne
untergehe könnten jetzt halt entweder
hier in diese richtung laufen also hier
vorne wo diese schnee wings ist oder
einfach dort in den wald rein und ich
bin auch ganz ehrlich es ist zwar ein
bisschen furcht einflößender hier vorne
jetzt in den wald rein zu laufen ich
finde es allerdings eigentlich ganz cool
die von uns wieder so ein stinkendes
foult hier und wir lassen uns aber von
nicht beunruhigen gerade wir laufen hier
einfach durch ich hab ja vier hunde bei
mir das heißt wenn irgendwelche monster
auftreten sollten hier vorn haben so
eine kleine grotte ich finde das schon
schön und sobald ich könnte mir auch
vorstellen in seinem wald einfach zu
bleiben aber wir haben ja in dieser
staffel minecraft mit luca die
möglichkeit dieses zu entdecken wir sind
nicht so begrenzt wie in minecraft mit
lukas 51 deswegen will ich einfach so
viel wie möglich ein deckel hier geht es
ganz ganz weit runter keiner rein fallen
bitte
das
leben am limit
[Musik]
wie schön ist es hier
bekommt wirklich überall mitteln das
sieht hier wirklich so unfassbar geil
aus mit diesem see hier mittendrin
zwischen diesen kleinen kügelchen und
den berg metallica 4
[Musik]
er hat
wir hatten ein schwert in der hand
[Musik]
ohne uns wärst du am arsch ich war jetzt
danke schön ich glaube keiner meiner
hunde ist gestorben wir haben vier stück
alle noch am start die haben allerdings
ein bisschen schaden genommen ich dachte
ich würde auch gerne fuchs haben aber
ich weiß nicht wie ich solche füchse
zehn verbrauchern gebühren oder leben
wir so lieben
wie
schön ist es hier bitte
ich bin mir uns ehrlich
das heißt ganz große ruckelt ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich finde ja unfassbar
schön hier vorne geht so ein kleiner
seiten fluss rhein wir haben hier einen
etwas größeren see und können auch hier
einige sachen machen wir haben hier
kohle wir haben hier was entlasten
ich schmeiße mal kurz mal eine schere
weg das ganz normal die pilze gut wir
laufen allerdings weiter freund ich will
wirklich ein bisschen was entdecken in
alle richtungen ich kann jetzt mal ein
bisschen nach dahin laufen zum beispiel
so dass wir hier halt wirklich alles
versuchen so ein bisschen zu entdecken
ich habe auch keine ahnung dass er jetzt
wieder für komische konstruktionen sind
hier vorn sind auf jeden fall noch
einige süße beeren
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich bin schon sehr
sehr begeistert von dieser modifikation
bei uns ob plenty aber hier ist eine
spontane zwei macsteel
[Musik]
das ist mir zu stressig hier
das hier alles so überdachtes und da
können die ganze zeit monsters bonn
deswegen ab weiter irgendwo irgendeine
richtung laufen freunde ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich weiß nicht auf was wir
gerade nach der suche sind ich habe
irgendwie bock auf eine wüste bin ich
ganz ehrlich weil wir so ein bisschen
weiter dann haben wir haben viel platz
um wirklich mal was zu bauen und darauf
habe ich auch wirklich baff wir haben
hier vorne erstmal wie schaffe ich
doch nicht nein das sieht auch schon
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr schön hier
aus auch sehr interessant hier vorne mit
diesem was ist denn das schilf oder
irgendwie auch so gräser allerdings bin
ich auch hier ganz ehrlich ich finde es
ein bisschen zu random ich hätte bock
auf so ein bisschen berge oder irgendwie
sowas wertvoll erschrocken dass hier im
[Musik]
wenn kinder läuft wir wollen uns nicht
mit krokodilen hier anlegen das ist gar
nichts für mich in dieser bereich ich
will einfach irgendwas geil mit bergen
am liebsten und in der mitte richtig
geil hätte riesige fläche wo ich sachen
bauen kann also nicht so wie hier wo
alles so verwinkelt ist mir zu beugen
klar dass wir natürlich auch ganz
entspannt aber ich habe bock eine menge
sachen zu machen in diesem korrekten
sprachen lernen aber gut wir laufen
weiter ich weiß auch nicht was das hier
ist ich habe immer noch schuss von mons
dann irgendwas das jetzt so pilz spinnen
irgendwie auftreten hier vorne sieht es
wieder sehr sumpfig aus also aufpassen
dass jetzt nicht noch wieder
[Musik]
auf dem weg
ich baue man hier vorne noch so ein
bisschen zuckerrohr ab weil das jetzt
ihr gerade perfekt so rumsteht und hier
gewachsen ist die sache ist allerdings
dass ich mich ja leider mit dieser
modifikation bei uns oppland ich noch
nicht so gut auskenne das jetzt
beurteilen kann ob das hier wirklich so
minecraft dschungel ist oder ob das
irgendwas ist was in dieser modifikation
mit dazu kam bei den dschungel ist
korrigiert mich gerne in den kommentaren
aber meines wissens nach eines der
seltensten biome in minecraft und das
wäre natürlich wenn wir einen entdeckt
hätten ich weiß man nicht
ich höre die ganze zeit im schwimmen und
ich weiß nicht ob das irgend ein
krokodil wieder ist oder keine ahnung
war es okay ich habe 64 zu gehör das
heißt wir gehen jetzt einfach mal rüber
in diesem dschungel rein ich weiß halt
nicht ob das wirklich ein dschungel ist
oder ob das irgendwas ist was durch
diese modifikation dazu kommen
ich habe jedem ding was hier auf die
beiden herum läuft irgendwie angst
[Musik]
kann ich bitte noch mehr alles voll
watson hier bitte um ein verdammter gott
sind diese affen niedlich aber ich
glaube die angst vorm ja oder ja er
läuft auf jeden fall von mir weg
dementsprechend müssen uns ein bisschen
außer entfernung an gucken wir haben
hier melonen also scheint wirklich ein
dschungel zu sein und hier guck mal
hinter dir
ist gerade da vorne die tiere dem
affenkäfig egal wie lassen ihn einfach
mal hier ich glaube die hat ein bisschen
schiss vor mir oder
ja es ist er abgehauen
[Musik]
ich könnte mich comedy hundefreunden
sich auch schon den affen an also ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich mag es hier es ist
zwar verwinkelt und das will ich
eigentlich nicht allerdings haben wir
eine menge mehr lohnen daraus können wir
uns melonen machen und die essen wir
haben eine menge affen mit dem können
wir das tape auch irgendwie interagieren
allerdings haben wir wahrscheinlich auch
hier so wie ich dieses diese
modifikation kenne eine menge neuer
monster
aber ist schon echt cool
ich weiß nicht wie ihr das seht und ich
bin noch ganz ehrlich ich hatte das zu
beginn von minecraft mit lukas dafür
zwei als weder in diesem wald geschossen
habe ich das auch eigentlich mir schon
so zusammengerückt beziehungsweise das
so geplant und mich darauf eingestellt
dass wir in diesem wald bleiben werden
ein kleines dorf bauen werden bisschen
dies das aber ich könnte mich auch mit
joel anfreunden
ist sehr wild
ich
würde mich jetzt mal ganz kurz hier
vorne glaube ich einfach direkt
niederlassen ein ganz kurz die eben zwei
fackeln hinstellen dass ihr ganzen hier
mal erst mal kurz sitz macht ich weiß
nicht wo die anderen beiden chaoten sind
da kommen sie an perfekt um es noch mal
ganz kurz sitzt er hier vorne läuft
direkt hoch der auf den warten eben ganz
kurz dann kann ich ihn auslachen lassen
man muss ja nicht im wasser hier vor
nachdem com jetzt
wirklich nicht zu viel verlangt die kurz
hochzukommen perfekt sein jetzt setzt
sich mal hier vorne kurzem bettchen hin
und ich würde hier erst mal ganz kurz
bleiben ich finde es hier sehr sehr sehr
sehr knapp ich versuche mich immer so
ein bisschen zumindest hoch zu bauen so
dass wir uns hier so ein bisschen
zumindest umschauen können es ist sehr
verbucht hat wir haben eine menge bäume
wir haben vorne eine kleine höhle wir
haben hier den sonnenuntergang und hier
geht der fluss sagen der forscherin
lachs oben gammeln kette bock auf ein
bisschen größere fläche aber das können
wir noch mal schauen ich würde an der
stelle jetzt allerdings die heutige
mannschaft mit betten meine lieben
freunde der dschungel ist geil wir
werden auf jeden fall ein paar folgen
bleiben das heißt ich werde mich auch
eine kleine bates erstmal bauen in der
nächsten episode gibt mir tipps für den
dschungel schreibt mir sachen die
kommentare die ich machen sondern wenn
euch das heute wieder gefallen hat das
kind einen daumen hoch unter dem video
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke eine neue videos dieser minecraft
mit lukas staffel 2 nicht verpassen
wollte die sonne ist da hinten schon
fast untergegangen ich finde das so
wundervolle mit den ganzen farben und so
und bevor ihr gleich wieder in die luft
fliegt würde ich auch sagen wie lege ich
mich
noch nicht wenn die zeit mal ganz kurz
nutzen
ganz kurz nutzen um hier an der seite
mal ganz
ist erst mal was du idiot
wird dann jetzt schlafen gehen jetzt
klappt auch
wir sehen uns morgen wieder um 18 uhr
nicht auf diesen dschungel zu entdeckt
also schaltet mal wieder einen chip
[Musik]